imagine that a researcher asks you to
write down your most important goal then
once you've done that they give you a
story about trees and ask you to read it
to yourself the way you've trees produce
leaves is one of the many examples of
the orderly patterns created by nature
it says subconsciously the thought of
trees sprouting leaves in an orderly
fashion fills you with determination and
then the researchers ask you some
questions about your most important goal
how likely are you to pursue it this was
a real study done in 2014 in which
researchers found that being exposed to
a story about order would be more
motivating than a similar story about
randomness and that's based in the
concept of priming the idea that
exposure to a stimulus so a word or a
concept can cause you to change your
response to a completely different
stimulus so for this study researchers
switched out the word order or
randomness in the story and they found
that exposure to the word order would
prompt a person to say they were more
motivated to pursue a goal if that
sounds a little too simple to be true
well it probably is many labs a group of
186 researchers have been trying to
recreate a lot of psychology studies
like that using over 60 different labs
around the world and using much larger
sample sizes of 14 in the 28 studies
that they tested including that order
and randomness study couldn't be
replicated with the same significance
another of the many lab studies tested
the impact of a word scramble with
either priming words conveying heat or
cold or a neutral control on people's
perception of global warming and while
the original study found that those who
had solved heat related word scrambles
were more likely to say they were
worried about the climate many labs
couldn't replicate that now that doesn't
mean priming
doesn't exist semantic priming has been
observed in several well-respected
studies researchers have tracked eye
movement and and gaze lengths and found
that people are quicker to read word
groups that are semantically related so
gold and silver is read more quickly
than gold and horse another study showed
that people are faster to recall pairs
of words if they're semantically related
to each other
the researchers followed up on their own
studies trying to replicate their
results and yeah they found that the
priming effects did keep happening
although not always in the same exact
way it's safe to say that some
tick priming does happen when you are
reading and listening your brain
understands what's going on a lot faster
if you hear the words and parts of
speech that you jellyfish brain
understands what's going on a lot faster
if you hear the words and parts of
speech that you expect that questionable
idea that priming influences behavior
well that's part of a larger issue
called the replication crisis my own
master's thesis many years ago was an
accidental example of this in my
undergraduate degree I found a possible
thriving effect where teachers could be
influenced to give higher grades to
essays if they were primed by words in
those essays if the student talked about
success rather than failure that was a
fascinating results of my Master's I
spent a long time refining testing and
making a larger study that was a
scientifically rigorous as I couldn't
make it and I found no effect nothing at
all I'm like sure I still got my degree
proving the null hypothesis is still a
success but it's still hurt to know I
was wrong the replication crisis is the
realization across a lot of branches of
medicine life behavioral and linguistic
studies that results we thought were
statistically significant might not be
maybe the sample size was too small or
biases and sampling weren't accounted
for like they only tested us college
students maybe there wasn't enough
control for the impact of the testing
environment or there was human error in
the test design or maybe it's just the
sheer complexity of humans as subjects
to begin with it turns out that
researchers are not always properly and
openly accounting for all those factors
they the university's PR department to
present their findings without talking
about the limitations or maybe if the
results are negative or unimpressive
they just get filed away and never
published it doesn't mean that every
statistical study you see is bunk
absolutely not but when you see bold
claims about how your brain can be
influenced by the language you read and
they all seem a little bit too good to
be true it's right to be skeptical
researchers have to take the replication
crisis and learn from it adapt their
methods and keep trying to understand
ourselves the script for this video was
put together by a team of writers
including Gretchen McCulloch whose
podcast length I azzam is both wonderful
and linked in the description below
you